how do you movement correct yeah did I  know you mom Thomas Carrasco with the  Department of Defense you were employed  at the homecoming chances for support so  we received a complain about that  program have a seat please  did you get started you acknowledge that  your participation in the homecoming  transitional support center is voluntary  and unforced I just need you to verbally  acknowledge that oh yeah yes I do  mismatch homecoming is a safe space to  process your military experience and  think about what comes next  they tell us the truth kind of yeah  under these men are holding on to that's  exactly what we need to do don't give a  [ __ ] what it is we're trying to do  [Music]  okay that's a good place to stop  [Music]  you